I've given y'all a classic
they're gonna talk about this one for
years and years
I only do this for certain people it's
called GQ
hey yo check this out this is DJ Khaled
this is my life and sneakers
another one
[Music]
I mean I've always loved sneakers I just
remember as a kid I would beg my mother
and father to get me some Jordans I love
basketball I love Michael Jordan just
watching the game and wanting to be in
the game the excitement to see Michael
Jordan wear the Jordans and slam dunking
and being my favorite player you're
saying I wanted to wear the sneakers
it's crazy I was going through some
Throwbacks when I was a kid and I see me
wearing you know the ones and the Breads
and my closet I would never throw my
sneakers away and I didn't realize I was
a collector as a kid I just wanted them
and I would never want to give them away
I just I would clean them so much when I
beat him up and I just love sneakers I
basically lived in the mall because my
mom and dad used to own suit stores
clothing stores you know my mom and dad
would take me to work so I'll be in the
mall so I would always go to Foot Locker
and Champs and the funny thing is that I
used to work for Champs you know when
the sneakers came in I would buy them
but I used to sell mixtapes people used
to come in the store and I would sell
Sneakers but I would put a mixtape in
the sneaker when they go ring up I was
always in the mix
when shoes came out so I was right there
it's crazy how it's evolved you know
what I'm saying because back then you
could go in the store and get them and
not saying you can't get them now but
now it's like a shoe come out it's a
line around the building it's a concert
it's an event and it just shows you the
the evolution of not just Michael Jordan
as the player but just the lifestyle
that he brought to us and how we all
connect to it
hip-hop is a big part of sneakers and we
have to credit hip-hop as well for
taking it to the next level vinyl and
sneakers was my thing and still my thing
so the connection was always there
hip-hop sneakers lifestyle my Idols from
Michael Jordan to Jay-Z and other great
rappers was wearing Michael Jordan shoes
that's what it's about being Timeless
it's just like when I make a record I
want to make a record that sounds great
today but I want to make a record that's
going to play Forever and that's
something that Jordan did with his
sneakers you know I mean he put some
sneakers out but they're from the
beginning of his career to now
they're Timeless you can't be big time
unless you're big time
you know I mean you can't be big time if
you don't move big time
and I'm big time
I'm living proof of you can make it
happen
be relentless you know what I'm saying
be great don't stop and keep going
that's why I named my sneaker keep going
it just it just connects it it fits
right why don't you walk into your top
five sneakers now I mean I mean that you
know when you say top five stickers that
sounds average to me because I got too
much greatness to just be talking about
five how about we talk about stuff that
you don't have and stuff that
I might have and stuff that
let me take you to my my world
all right so check this out you know
everybody be wanting to show the sneaker
room you know I did that we trendsetters
I been did that and loved everybody
that's doing it because that's what it's
about let's Inspire each other but I
wanted to go in my backyard because the
weather's beautiful they ain't believing
us
Michael Jordan did
[Music]
I name my own shoes
I love these because you know I've been
in this meeting but these shoes was for
a meeting that never happened so I'm
gonna call it the meeting that never
happened
I got him though why have one when you
can have three one
another one
another one call me MJ
get a close-up of this MJ signature
mjworthies
he did 38 points that night in these
I usually don't like to pull this one
out because it's going to be a lot of
how to Cali get it and I want to keep my
relationship
how can I say my face clean but I do
have it this is GQ so MJ signature MJ
wore these this is what you call
Historic I love these I call these all
my favorite colors
yo most grab me the duffel
I call these what a great color
what a great color
yeah you know the Travis is you know
that not only am I a fan of causes um
sneakers I love his art but I made sure
I got everyone that he puts out I mean
everybody wants to know how much my
sneakers are worth this is just like the
corner of my closet on everything I love
I own three warehouses and three houses
with sneakers and three warehouses with
sneakers I don't lie I don't make things
up I'm just telling you the truth do you
want to know the worth you can't put
money or a number amount on these things
you know why because it means something
to me personally I don't sell my
sneakers I might trade and I know other
people might have some I want well I
might have something they want it's
super dope that we can get on the phone
and just catch a Vibe and talk about
sneakers and trade and have fun with it
that's what it's about so everybody
knows me threes and fours and what all
the Jordans are my favorite but these
are the Russ Westbrooks I'm gonna tell
you a quick story I'm not supposed to
have these but I found a way to get them
so I call these I'm not supposed to have
these I love the dior's let me tell you
why I love the dior's because I have one
pair I have another pair and I have
another pair somewhere upstairs too I
end up getting three they told me these
are hard to get so I went and got three
I call them now they told me it was hard
to get so I went and got three you see
where I'm going with this my sneak is a
name different
they mean something different than me so
it couldn't mean the same thing that
they mean to me because each sneaker is
a personal thing in my life it might
have been a cover shoot it might have
been a video I wore them it might have
been something I went through and that
certain time in my life so my collection
is personal to me you know they'd be
hating and when they hate that's a whole
nother category for the haters it's
called they ain't believing us God did
there's a lot of reasons why I love the
threes look at these Kobe 3s not only is
the threes my favorites a lot of
people's favorite and it goes back to
why I love the breads the fours you know
Jordan wears socks a certain way with
the threes and the fours I mean if you
think about the legacy of the shoe and
what the shoe has been through that's
the definition of Timeless I got these
as a gift these are samples have y'all
seen this anywhere
I've never seen it there are samples but
guess what I call it I've never seen it
nowhere thank you for the gift it's so
many man I got a shout out to Soulfly
because you know I got represent home
team look at these the um covers let me
say let me show you something about
these look at the leather come come
close
that's a different type of leather I
call these home team love 305. these are
Macklemore's right that's what you call
them right I call them I love the color
that's what I call it I love the color
of what y'all call these the splatters
OVO Drakes I call these they ain't
believe in me they ain't believing us
Drake did they call these Motorsport
fives I'll change the name I call them
they're mine they call these a trophy
rooms right
shout out to Trophy wrong you see the
trophy room left I call him MJ DNA it's
called family don't ever play yourself
trophy rules to loot don't stop keep
going
these are the Ducks I got these as a
gift let me tell you a story about these
to both left side of the feet I don't
have the right side that's how rare they
are they gave me two laps I call these
Jamaica Kingston I wore these in um the
Holy Mountain video I've been wore these
yet shout out to the Ducks they always
show me love shout out my brother nipsy
Hustle the great nipsy hustle look at
this this is so classic so clean
shouted the whole Marathon team shouting
the nip
look at that
and a threes too so these right here
look at these fours
Interscope fours in the music business
shout out to Universal records uh
Interscope I call this I don't know the
full story behind this but I got them
I'm Gonna Keep the name of these you
know I love naming my sneakers but this
name for these sneakers is proper some
things you just don't change I call them
undefeated
I can relate to that undefeated we
forever we timeless
keep going so these right here they call
the fragments right you know what I
really call these
I call it the stamp of approval
because you know you might have these
and you think you know it's so funny I
seen the other day somebody had these
and they're like yo I got the theories
you know what I'm saying but it had no
stamps
it's a big difference it's called
Stamford approval I got love for
everybody that support All Team Jordan I
support all my brothers and sisters and
my brother J Balvin he give me these I
call these get ready for this new
release
this is all release get ready for his
new release that's what I call him you
know you got to have something to get
ready for right get ready for his new
release hey yo Balvin see what I just
said right they out of here now
so they call these a soul come look at
these
look at these
I changed the name
you know I love threes I call them we
Global
I call them we Global
what you think I'm all over the world
with this bringing more duffel bags
thank you my brother
come get a close-up I call these Los
Angeles
Los Angeles
[Music]
Los Angeles
Los Angeles
Los Angeles
I know y'all calling the unions I know I
call them Los Angeles yeah I got the
orange ones there too don't ever play
yourself I got them all and I love them
all
first of all I want to say God bless and
big up the great Virgil Long Live virgin
speaking of Virgil let me show you how I
do it come in because it's a lot
look at this I'm directing you this GQ
we do [ __ ] different over here all right
all that trying to be cool and all that
you hear the background noise it's
called real light show more see all
these right here that's never been worn
and all these have never been worn I
call them I haven't had time to wear
them yet show them all call them I show
them all and haven't had time to wear
them yet I know I think I'm crazy nah
I'm Khalid
I'm pure
you know what I mean when you yeah
biggest in all categories I'm showing
you all this but let's keep going matter
of fact let me show you keep going
this is what it's all about this is the
most important segment right here it
always got to go back to the journey
look how it started I remember getting
my first Jordan gifted to me and they
just put the we the best patch on there
and has my name right here look this is
when the meeting officially started of
course I was in the meeting since I was
a kid but when I got these the meeting
started
and then these came
and these came
then these came
he's right here
are so special I call these to keep
going
we the best cattle Jordans this leather
had to go through so many approvals only
one person that could sign off on this
leather and that was Michael Jordan
because it's the most expensive leather
and that means you have to go over
budget making the shoot and MJ signed
off for me when you get your hands on
this and you feel this leather and put
it on you're going to understand what
I'm saying keep going I want to pick up
the entire team to be the best team in
the Jordan team because we all got
together and we just as a team effort we
just sat down and really talked about
what keep going means and Michael Jordan
is a definition of keep going that's why
I relate so much of him being my idol
because I've never seen him stop he's
not stopping now he keeps going and
going and keep winning and keep you know
he's Timeless I have a rule where we the
best everybody got to perform at a high
level not just me and that's what keep
going is about it's about performing at
a high level and not stopping and not
giving up and keep going and keep
winning this my brother you'll say
everybody everybody heard of Reggie
signers and my a lot of people know
Reggie Sanders you know they keep
calling me like yo Khaled give me Reggie
sign this content I'm like yo I don't
know Reggie Sanders but I know him you
know what I'm saying because
you got a hard job you're saying because
he's the one made this happen for me him
and MJ they believed in me I used to be
on Reggie like calling him you know
since the kid I've been you know
collecting sneakers and through my
career I've been grinding and grinding
and my loyalty to Jordan and Reggie is
on another level and um I'll never
forget when MJ told red whatever he
wants green lighted you know what I'm
saying I've been Team Jordan but I was
officially Team Jordan when he told
Reggie green lighted so that's when I
got my ring and that's what it's about
and I want the young world to know the
hard work pays off if you keep working
hard be relentless
be great be grateful I'm saying you know
be confident you know saying Michael
Jordan's my idol for a reason it's all
paying off now not only my team Jordan I
got a ring you know saying these are my
rings
and we just getting started too and what
we saw was the positivity he's the same
person every single day
he's the keep going guy he's the
positive guy he loves Jordan brand that
right there he was authentic
uncompromised he earned the spot very
aspirational thank you that's just what
we love about Cali he's coming to you
how he comes your Instagram is how he's
coming to me every single day pure
what's next are we the best for Jordan
brand well the goal is
um because you know you got to have a
goal and you have to you know one thing
we we made it to the championship and we
got a ring we got a few rings now
now consistency is key Team Jordan is
part of my life
it's part of part of my legacy it's part
of my DNA we're forever
right now Jordan can say age no more
Jordans for Cali oh well I'm Gonna Keep
wearing them
that's what's so beautiful about loving
something and being loyal to something
you know what I mean keep going
keep going
keep going bless up I want to thank GQ
for coming to my house my backyard and
just vibing with me having fun
um shout out to all the sneaker heads
worldwide more importantly shout out to
all the fans out there that support
Brothers like me I want to thank you for
supporting me and thank you GQ for
giving me your outlet to talk to my fans
and having fun with the people enjoy
this my life and sneakers and I hope you
get motivated inspired by this and
hopefully you could be here to show my
life and sneakers and do the same thing
I did love
foreign